madame monsieur bonsoir réélu
triomphalement il y a un an le président
américain Bill Clinton va-t-il être
obligé de démissionner ou sera-t-il
destitué pour incitation à faux
témoignage pour mensonge donc comme le
fut en son temps Richard Nixon la
question est réellement posée ce soir en
effet la presse américaine s'est emparée
d'une nouvelle affaire une liaison
amoureuse entre le président et une
stasière de la Maison Blanche qui lui
aurait demandé de dissimuler alors
qu'elle était elle-même interrogée dans
le cadre d'une autre affaire celle de
Paula Jones qui accuse également Bill
Clinton d'avoir voulu la forcer à une
relation sexuelle deux affaires c'est
beaucoup pour le président qui se
retrouve sur la défensive obligé de
s'expliquer devant toute l'Amérique
Washington
marisbgo un président américain obligé
de s'expliquer sur une affaire sexuelle
en pleine entrevue avec Yasser
Arafat ces accusations sont fausses et
je demande à tout le monde de dire la
vérité dès hier soir Bill Clinton était
déjà venu nier à la télévision à une
heure de grande écoute les accusations
portées contre lui monsieur le Président
est-ce que c'est vrai ce n'est pas
vrai après Paula Jones voici donc le
nouveau visage par qui le scandale
arrive Monica levinski il y a 3 ans elle
était stagiaire à la Maison Blanche elle
avait 21 ans selon certaines allégations
elle aurait alors entretenu pendant 18
mois une liaison avec Clinton Clinton
qui lui aurait ensuite demandé de taire
cette relation et donc de mentir aux
enquêteurs chargés de l'affaire Paula
Jones selon cette analyste politique que
nous avons rencontré ce matin c'est
cette suspicion de subornation de
témoins qui est très
grave les gens se moquent de la vie
sexuelle du président mais il ne se
moquent pas du fait qu'il ait pu
utiliser sa position pour faire pression
sur
quelqu'un le procureur indépendant char
de cette nouvelle affaire le voici kenf
star véritablement assailli ce matin par
les médias américains selon l'bdomadaire
Newsweek il serait déjà en possession
d'enregistrement de conversation
téléphonique entre lewiinski et l'une de
ses amis ces enregistrement serait
compromettant pour Clinton ces
accusations si bien sûr elles sont
prouvées sont gravissimes pour le
président par jure subornation de
témoins obstruction de la justice pour
un citoyen américain cela équivaut à de
prison et pour le président des
États-Unis cela pourrait engager une
procédure de destitution si bien sûr ces
accusations sont prouvé il faut
maintenant attendre les conclusions du
procureur indépendant chargé de
l'enquête